>>> AS OF THIS MORNING, MORE
THAN 675,000 AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
KILLED BY CORONAVIRUS.
THAT IS MORE DEATHS THAN IN THE
1918 FLU PANDEMIC.
IT'S APPROXIMATELY 1 IN 490
AMERICANS, MOTHERS, FATHERS,
FRIENDS, BROTHERS, ALL GONE.
THAT MANY PEOPLE COULD FILL
ALMOST TEN NFL STADIUM.
NEARLY 2,000 AMERICANS ARE DYING
EVERY DAY NOW.
CNN'S DR. SANJAY GUPTA TAKES A
LOOK AT HOW WE REACHED THIS
DEVASTATING TOLL.
>> Reporter: A LITTLE MORE THAN
A CENTURY AGO, AN INFLUENZA
PANDEMIC RAVAGED AMERICA.
>> THERE WERE FOUR WAVES IN THE
1918/1919 PANDEMIC.
THE TWO GREATEST OCCURRED IN THE
FALL OF 1918 AND THE WINTER OF
1919.
>> Reporter: DR. HOWARD MARQUEL
STUDIED EPIDEMICS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
>> THERE WERE NO VACCINES FOR
INFLUENZA.
WE DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS CAUSED BY
A VIRUS.
>> Reporter: BEST PROJECTIONS,
675,000 PEOPLE DIED.
FAST FORWARD TO TODAY, A GRIM
MILESTONE.
DEATHS FROM THE CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC HAVE SURPASSED THAT
FIGURE.
MORE THAN 675,000 PEOPLE HAVE
NOW DIED OF COVID-19 IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> JUST SADNESS.
BECAUSE IT DIDN'T HAVE TO BE
THIS HIGH.
>> Reporter: IT IS TRUE THAT
BACK IN 1918, THE POPULATION WAS
A THIRD OF WHAT IT IS TODAY.
BUT THAT ENTIRE POPULATION WAS
AT THE MERCY OF THE PANDEMIC.
BECAUSE THERE WERE NO VACCINES.
BUT TODAY, A DIFFERENT PROBLEM
IN THE UNITED STATES.
A RE RELCK -- RELUCTANCE TO USE
THE VACCINE.
>> IT IS WHAT IS DRIVING THE
SURGE IN HOSPITALIZATIONS' NEED
FOR INTENSIVE CARE UNIT AND ALSO
THE RECORD NUMBER OF DEATHS THAT
WE'RE SEEING.
>> WE HAVE HAD SOME CAPACITY
OPEN UP, AND IT IS NOT BECAUSE
THESE PATIENTS ARE MIRACULOUSLY
GETTING BETTER AND GOING HOME.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY'RE DYING.
>> Reporter: FEDERAL HEALTH
OFFICIALS SAY WE'RE IN A
PANDEMIC OF THE UNVACCINATED.
>> WHEN 99% OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE DYING OF COVID TODAY DON'T
HAVE A VACCINE, THAT'S PERFECT
PROOF THAT YOU NEED TO BE
VACCINATED.
>> Reporter: IT ALL RAISES AN
UNCOMFORTABLE QUESTION.
WHAT ARE WE WILLING TO ACCEPT
WHEN IT COMES TO DEATHS?
THIS IS THE DEATH TOLL OVER TIME
SO FAR.
1,000 IN MARCH OF 2020.
300,000 BY THE END OF LAST YEAR.
TWICE THAT MANY BY THE SUMMER.
SOME NOW ASK, COULD THERE BE A
MILLION TRAGIC DEATHS BEFORE
THIS IS ALL OVER?
>> I CERTAINLY HOPE NOT.
I HOPE NOT.
I DON'T BELIEVE AT ALL THAT THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT IS AN
INEVITABILITY BY ANY MEANS.
IF WE GET THE OVERWHELMING
PROPORTION OF THE POPULATION
VACCINATED, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
SEE THAT AT ALL.
>> Reporter: BUT THAT MEANS
GETTING MOST OF SOME 70 MILLION
ELIGIBLE ADULTS VACCINATED.
AN EFFORT THAT HAS BEEN POISONED
BY POITICS AND MISINFORMATION.
THE WORST IT HAS BEEN IN A
HUNDRED YEARS.
>> IT'S NEVER BEEN THIS LEVEL OF
ANGER AND POLITICIZATION AND
DISTRUST.
>> Reporter: 2021 ISN'T 1918.
THEY LACKED THE SCIENCE TO
PREVENT 675,000 DEATHS.
WHEREAS, WE, TO A GREAT